what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another installment of our
beyond omega level series where we break
down the most powerful characters in
comics also uh we're focusing on mandrak
obviously from the title here's a
question i have for you guys next week
um i'm thinking about because like we've
been going in for like a long time even
just taking a week off for going to new
york and doing street photography even
then that's kind of like
not necessarily the the full-on break
that i need one of the things that i'm
thinking about doing is just taking next
week and just covering a singular story
um and i'm debating on doing something
like batman hush because it's
technically a 12 part series and just do
like two episodes a day for the whole
week um and that way like it's just it's
a simple no must no fuss kind of thing
let me know what you guys think about
that because i kind of like the idea but
uh in any event the mandrake of course
was the dark monitor now i wasn't really
able to find the exact moment where this
character was requested but i know he
has been requested several times and now
i'm finally giving in and basically
covering some more grant morrison
nonsense now because this is grant
morrison even though this character has
only appeared in a handful of issues
explaining him is probably going to be a
little difficult because his backstory
is a bit convoluted uh but we're gonna
try and make it as easy to understand as
possible so mandrak was created by grant
morrison and doug mink and first
appeared in final crisis superman beyond
number one in 2008 and the premise of
final crisis is basically that there is
a war between the new gods and dark
sides forces and both darkseid and orion
die now orion crash lands on earth and
then in kind of a cryptic way tells this
guy dan turpin they did not die he's in
you all now what he's referring to here
is that when darkseid supposedly died
what really happened is that his essence
came to earth and it inhabited a human
host as did the essences of some of his
servants on apocalypse and so darkseid's
first host was a crime boss that went by
the name boss darkseid and then he
switched to dan turpin's body which he
altered to look like his original body
but regardless darkseid's plan is to
spread the anti-life equation to
everybody on earth and thereby conquer
the world and so to do that he needs to
eliminate the biggest threats to his
plan and of course that includes
superman so he arranges for an explosion
at the daily planet to mortally wound
lois lane forcing superman to travel to
the 31st century to find a way to save
her now superman is offered this chance
by zillow valla a member of a cosmic
race known as the monitors who are
basically in charge of maintaining order
throughout the dc multiverse obviously
they failed and so she tells superman
that lois can be healed by a substance
known as the bleed which she describes
as the material between the 52 universes
of the multiverse a drop of which is
capable of either healing or
annihilation but which only monitors can
touch and so superman goes with her of
course and he finds himself on a ship
with different versions of superman from
across the multiverse there's ultraman
the evil superman from earth 3 over man
a superman from a reality where the
germans won world war ii a quantum
superman from a universe where the laws
of physics are different and for some
reason a version of shazam now the ship
makes its way beyond the multiverse to a
place called limbo where they learn of
the threat that they've been recruited
to fight by reading a book made up of
every possible book now the book reveals
that in the beginning there was only one
entity known as the over monitor and the
over monitor finds a flaw within itself
and the over monitor sends a probe to
see what lies within the flaw and
discovers chaos in the forms of the
heroes villains lives deaths and stories
now here is where i should probably
point out that the entire purpose of the
superman beyond tie-in story to final
crisis is to allow grant morrison to
offer like a meta commentary on the
power of stories because that's the kind
of thing he likes to do but regardless
the over monitor decides that it has no
answer for the destruction that stories
would cause because stories were a
completely foreign concept to it and so
the over monitors probe withdraws and
the flaw is sealed by divine metals that
just so happen to take the shape of
superman which basically seals off the
multiverse where stories and narratives
are allowed to spread i told you this is
going to be kind of weird and a little
bit complicated but the monitors just
spend years looking at this giant metal
superman wondering is it here to protect
us or to harm us until the first
offspring of the original monitor a guy
known as dax novu decided to explore the
bleed and the flaw now dax novoo becomes
a sort of folk hero because it's
believed that he gave his life to bring
the monitor's knowledge of the bleeds
power and to lock away an entity known
as mandrak who's called the prime eater
of life now of course just as the
superman learn about all this a blast of
energy comes out of the book and they go
back to the ship and zillow valla
informs the group that mandrake the dark
monitor has risen and that he has found
them and that all is lost now ultraman
the evil superman from earth 3 then
reveals that he has read the last page
of the infinite book and that mandrak is
building a bridge from the void to the
multiverse and that his plan is to kill
everybody within the multiverse now
mandrax forces invade limbo and superman
and ultraman argue over whether they
should side with mandrak or fight him
and they eventually realize they both
need aspects of superman to power the
big metal superman that's supposed to be
protecting the multiverse so the quantum
superman fuses superman and ultraman
together and the big metal superman
which is called the cosmic armor
superman which i do have a full video on
if you want to watch it basically wakes
up now zillow valla explains that this
cosmic armor superman which she calls a
thought robot was the last great gift of
dak's novu and is said to be capable of
adapting to meet any future threat and
designed to save all existence against
the ultimate enemy and so the superman
robot is then confronted by mandrak
who's holding up a capsule filled with
the bleed which superman needs in order
to heal lois and then challenges him to
come and take it from him so as they
begin fighting mandrak reveals that he
is powered by the blood of 52 universes
and the heat of 10 billion suns
indicating that he's already destroyed
all of those universes now as the battle
between them goes on mandrak grows
increasingly stronger and the thought
robot increases in power to match him
and so as they fight civilization and
all of reality crumbles around them and
superman finally discovers the true
origin of mandrak and that dax novu had
not sacrificed himself to imprison
mandrak but that mandrak was daksnovu
himself of course superman seemingly
defeats mandrak but the battle does
enough damage to the thought robot that
is ultimately destroyed so that's the
origin of mandrake like i said pretty
convoluted but let's get into his power
so mandrak is the most powerful of all
the monitors and after becoming addicted
to the bleed he essentially becomes a
vampire that has a constant thirst for
the bleed now like we said earlier he
produces energy beams that have the heat
of 10 billion suns and he also has the
ability to fly he's telepathic and can
grow in power as needed to fight any
enemy as we saw with his battle with the
thought robot mandrake can not only
alter reality but can also go beyond
that and eliminate complete narratives
from existence but not only can he erase
someone from existence like any reality
warper basically could he couldn't make
it so entire realities had never existed
in the first place so for those of you
guys coming from marvel comics he's
basically a living ultimate nullifier
but to get an idea of how powerful
mandrak is we need only look at what
happens when he returns at the end of
final crisis so after darkseid is
defeated mandrak shows up to confront
superman and his minion ultraman who be
turned into a vampire and is carrying
the bodies of the spectre and the
radiant and the fact that he was able to
defeat and feed on these two entities is
absolutely insane you probably know
about the spectre who is the embodiment
of god's vengeance in the dc universe
but you may not have heard of the
radiant who's the embodiment of god's
mercy so they're basically two sides of
the same coin and are both divine
avatars that have an insane power level
and of course mandrak is eventually
defeated but it takes the combined might
of superman from dozens of different
universes the green lantern corps the
zoo crew which has captain carrot
captain carrot i love captain karen
captain carrots a super bunny
[Laughter]
but it takes captain carrot the zoo crew
which is basically an
animal version of the justice league the
mandrake son nexuotin another member of
the monitor race all of them to take
mandrak out so the fact that it takes
that much firepower to destroy mandrak
lets us know that he is far far beyond
omega level and just as a bonus right
just as like an aside if you're
wondering how it is that he's eventually
defeated it's because with him being a
vampire he has a stake made of green
light from hal jordan's ring driven
through his chest which is admittedly a
pretty badass way to die but i think
that's the simplest i can make man drag
i mean he's insanely powerful but i
doubt that we'll ever see him used again
in dc comics right i mean i guess you
could never truly rule it out but i
don't know with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching as always make sure
you leave a comment down below on
anybody you want to see that we have not
done before and i will catch you all
later
peace